Ladies and gentlemen!
The one, the only, Kurt Sloane!
Welcome back.
It is time for you to defend your title.
In another fight to the death.
Or you'll spend the rest of your life in prison.
Meet Mongkut.
Superior human specimen.
Bigger...
Stronger than any human being on the planet.
Never again.
We have to find a way to match this up.
They kidnapped your wife.
You have to start to train.
The strongest man doesn't always win.
But the smartest one does.
Your strengths against his weakness.
What's his weakness?
- That's a good question.
Just sit back
and enjoy the ride.
Bring it.
You interrupted my meditation.
Really? Does that help you stay calm?
I guess not.